it's a new challenge it's a new chapter
right after a year-long trial period
meghan markle and prince harry have
officially confirmed
their exit as working members of the
royal family
it's a very real thing to be going
through behind the scenes
buckingham palace issued a statement on
friday confirming the news
noting that harry and his grandmother
queen elizabeth ii
have spoken about the decision quote the
honorary military appointments and
royal patronages held by the duke and
duchess will therefore be returned to
her majesty before being redistributed
among working members of the royal
family the statement concludes
while all are saddened by their decision
the duke and duchess remain
much-loved members of the family the
decision that
i have made for my wife and i to step
back
is not one i made lightly but as far as
this goes
there really was no other option a
buckingham palace source adds that harry
and megan's decision to not return to
their royal roles
after the one-year review period was
quote made after conversations between
the duke of sussex and
members of the royal family and a
spokesperson for the duke and duchess
tells et
that the two remain committed to their
service in the uk
and around the globe adding quote we can
all live a life of service
service is universal i am very excited
about that
while the couple will no longer be
affiliated with the national theater
the rugby football league nor england
rugby
harry will remain an integral part of
the event he founded
the invictus games similarly megan will
remain the patron of mayhew an
animal welfare charity megan and harry
stepped down on march 31st of
last year and have since relocated to
montecito california
where they have continued to work with
several charities signed a production
deal with netflix
and have even started their own podcast
oh
and as if all that wasn't enough earlier
this month
the couple announced that they are
expecting their second child together
i'm told by sources close to the duke
and duchess that they did
call their family back at home in the uk
the queen
and the prince of wales and i understand
the duke of cambridge as well they were
all told
um the happy news before it was made
public and uh
it's something that the royal family
have been celebrating royal expert katie
nichol
recently told et that the two are ready
to talk publicly about their decision to
step down from the royal family
megan and harry will be opening up to
oprah winfrey for the first sit-down
interview since their engagement in
november 2017.
we are told that this is going to be a
wide-ranging interview
and that nothing is off limits we're
told megan will discuss motherhood
her philanthropy work what it was like
marrying into the royal family
and inevitably they're going to be
talking about what it was like to lead
the royal family their side of the story
has been told
through many other voices but not theirs
this i'm told is
their moment to sit down to tell the
truth in their own words
[Music]